the same Oswald as soon as he ascended
the throne being desirous that all his
nation should receive the Christian
faith we're off he had found happy
experience and vanquishing the
barbarians sent to the elders of the
Scots among whom himself had his
followers when in banishment had
received the sacrament of baptism
desiring they would send him a bishop by
whose instruction and ministry the
English nation which he governed might
be taught the advantages and received
the sacraments of the Christian faith
nor were they slow in granting his
request but sent him bishop Aden man of
singular meekness piety and moderation
zealous in the cause of God though not
altogether according to knowledge for he
was wanted to keep Easter Sunday
according to the custom of his country
which we have before so often mentioned
from the fourteenth to the twentieth
moon the northern province of the Scots
and all the nations of the pyx
celebrating Easter then after that
manner and believing that they therein
followed the writings of the holy and
praiseworthy
father Anatoli as' the truth of which
every skillful person can discern
but the Scots which dwelt in the south
of Ireland had long since by the
admonition of the Bishop of the
Apostolic See learned to observe Easter
according to the canonical custom
on the arrival of the bishop the king
appointed him his episcopal see in the
isle of Lindisfarne as he desired which
place as the tide flows and ebbs twice a
day is enclosed by the waves of the sea
like an island and again twice in the
day when the shore is left dry becomes
contiguous to the land the King also
humbly and willingly in all cases giving
ear to his admonitions applied himself
to build and extend the Church of Christ
in his kingdom wherein when the bishop
who was not skilful in the English
tongue preached to the gospel it was
most delightful to see the king himself
interpreting the Word of God to his
commanders and ministers for yet
perfectly learn the language of the
Scots during his long banishment
from that time many of the Scots came
daily into Britain and with great
devotion preached the word to those
provinces of the English over which King
Oswald reigned and those among them that
had received priests orders administered
to them the grace of baptism churches
were built in several places the people
joyfully flocked together to hear the
word money and lands were given off the
Kings bounty to build monasteries the
English great and small were by their
Scottish masters instructed in the rules
and observance of regular discipline for
most of them that came to preach were
monks Bishop Hayden was himself a monk
of the island called high whose
monastery was for a long time the chief
of almost all those of the northern
Scots and all those off the pits and had
the direction of their people that
island belongs to Britain being divided
from it by a small arm of the sea but
had been long since given by the Picts
who inhabit those parts of Britain to
these Scottish monks because they had
received the faith of Christ through
their preaching
[Music]